we've got a waypoint for the position of
the ship we'll probably go out of visual
range but we'll stay in radio contact
and just kind of check in wherever we
see anything or as we pass by landmarks
so you need to have a reference point to
be able to say where you are relative to
it if you're trying to use landmarks to
navigate something like the mountains or
the rocks and we're constantly trying to
remember where we are because you're
literally in a life raft and if anything
went wrong it would be bad
his last time out re managed to place a
video tag on a humpback whale a sixty
six thousand pound beast
but today he's hunting minke whales and
even in a known feeding ground they're
harder to spot weighing about 45,000
pounds less than humpbacks what's that
over there
I much visibility Carl but it's pretty
hard to spot a whale and the further
away than a few hundred meters the minke
whales are a lot more challenging
because there's they're smaller they're
faster and they don't surface nearly as
high they're real pain to work with
because they're difficult to see him
generally you see them once or twice and
then they're gone the horizontal
visibility is pretty low even with a
minke where they surface so low and
they're so small you can only see them
from a couple hundred meters but you can
probably hear the blow from you know two
or three times farther so what am I do
is I might shut down for a little bit
you know five minutes and just kind of
have a listen I shut us down so we'll do
that
[Music]
my most favorite times in the Antarctic
is when you can remove all of the human
sounds and it's a silence that you can
kind of feel
it seems kind of primitive you hear ice
crackling you hear glaciers rumbling
[Music]
yeah you're seal barking
when you can hear your heartbeat you
know that it's quiet
keep your eyes and ears open if you hear
a little blue that's I'm inky well